listen I have a constant problem with
Ronnie what do you mean well you know
he's another one he got a Twitter
following he's all excited about it
somebody wrote a horrible thing about me
and he retweets it is he crazy
I don't know he has no respect for me
this is a retweet ronnie is great please
let him replace washed up Stern Stern
Show too boring same crap over and over
time to pass the baton what's with you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
I thought you my pal was talking about
you don't know what I'm talking about
you don't know what you retweet I didn't
retweet anything you did what do you
mean you did it go type did you store
this Ronnie goes what's going on and I
told him because I didn't tweet that and
I'm like it did he goes no I didn't he
must have just gotten to the point where
Ronnie is great these weeds the first
three words are just he's in a rush
everyone is in a rush no I didn't I
didn't realize that that's what the
whole thing well don't you read I mean
it's only 20 words I mean once you read
the whole thing I'll tell ya why Jason
okay say I have Ronnie's Twitter feed
here if you would like if it isn't
believed that I'd show it take a look at
it Ronnie Ronnie tweeted retweeted
Ronnie why are you getting upset once
you [ __ ] need him in here you're who
told me I don't need him to show you you
said to him I say Jason this was you put
who said this [ __ ] know what's holy no
he didn't oh the whole world [ __ ]
told me not just Jason well once you
reach Rita did a lot of people knew yes
one of the tweeted it I don't remember
doing it judge Cavanaugh yeah I dildo
slipped and hit the button oh you're so
angry with me dude what did I do to you
accepted your life got you out of the
car let you stretch your legs or fail to
rinse you know he did this last year too
he did what are you talking to eat it
you retweeted somebody saying the show
is only good when Ronnie's on the air
yeah the show is only good when you're
on the is you do that how you do know if
I said that we did it that was a year
ago
I don't know if I remember that so is
the show only good when you're on Oh
he remembers everything so is the show
is the show only good when you're on is
that what you feel no maybe you do maybe
I should leave in you you want to host
the show oh I don't want to Mar I don't
come in you know show host the show it's
so easy I never said that get the [ __ ]
out I could have done this I never said
I could be the king of all me did I say
that bono no you're tweeting negative
things I don't I didn't really not
people I didn't read the tweet right
then that it was somebody else wrote the
tweet I didn't write it would you
retweeted it yep I didn't read the whole
thing do you think that's a good idea to
be sending retweets when you can't see
what someone's writing yeah he's gonna
read it
now he's gonna read it read it out loud
no read it out loud because it's always
fun when you read out loud
Ronny is great let's see Sandy Hook is a
hoax
Ronnie's the king of [ __ ] dad look at
this one Ronny is great and Frank
deserved it you didn't read the am Frank
part hey Ralph hey I believe Ronnie that
in that he didn't read the whole thing
thank you he's exactly what's wrong with
Twitter that's why it's ruined because
he's one of these morons who don't read
the tweet and they just react if
somebody tweeted running I think you're
great but you suck at this this and this
he's never accidentally tweeted that and
that he seems to read and Ronnie if
you're so into this Twitter why did you
get like an iPhone that you I can't even
imagine what it looks like on a
blackberry he have the blackberry cause
he likes the keyboard I have a very
tactile tactile yeah it's like little
cleats for the keyboard what do you got
what are you doing I bet you're doing a
video from Daytona just what it looks
like when Ronnie tweet Oh see I'm all
dumb to do you and T
[Laughter]
[Music]